Remember when everyone was bagging on millennials
for our “hookup culture.”
Joke’s on you, old people, turns out we’re
barely having sex!
Hello just friends, Julian here for DNews.
Smartphone apps can do anything.
Press the right buttons and you can order
a pizza, or get directions to pizza, or match
with someone on a dating app like Tinder and
trick them into bringing you pizza.
Apparently, though, some people actually use
Tinder for casual sex.
This has led to predictions that dating would
end and relationships would be replaced by
a string of one night stands.
And then a funny thing happened: researchers
asked millennials just how much sex they were
having and the answer was lower than anybody
was expecting.
It’s not just low compared to the crazy
expectations set by their prudent parents,
it’s the lowest it’s been since the 1940s.
Psychologist and author of the book Generation
Me Jean Twenge examined data from the General
Social Survey, which looks at American social
trends going back 70 years.
Twenge and other researchers analyzed over
26,000 responses to the GSS and examined how
many sexual partners people reported having
between the ages of 18 and 24.
6% of adults born in the late 1960s reported
having no partners at that age, while for
today’s adults born in the ‘90s, that
figure was closer to 15%.
Twenge remarked, "This generation appears
to be waiting longer to have sex, with an
increasing minority apparently waiting until
their early twenties or later.”
I know that’s why I didn’t have sex in
high school… because I was “waiting”...
But everything’s going to be ok, 18 year
old Julian, because the Center for Disease
control has also found that high school virgin
rates are on the rise.
Data published by the CDC last year showed
that 41% of high school students had had sex
at some point, compared to 54% of students
in 1991.
Millennials aren’t just waiting longer to
have sex either, they also report fewer sexual
partners on average compared to generations
past.
Another analysis of the GSS by Twenge found
that while baby boomers typically had 11.68
partners in their lifetime, millennials are
on pace to average only 8.26.
I don’t know how you can have sex with .26
people, but I’m a millennial so clearly
my experience is limited.
This all appears to contradict other data
about our newest crop of adults.
In 1972, 45% of young adults said premarital
sex was “not wrong at all.”
As of 2014, that number had jumped to 64%,
so you’d think they’d all be on board
the boner train to pleasure town.
Why the hedonism has died down despite more
openness to hedonism is something of a mystery
that the data can’t answer yet.
This hasn’t stopped people from speculating
though.
Twenge thinks that the rise of technology
means we have more ways to entertain ourselves,
so sex becomes less important.
And communicating through texting has diminished
face-to-face interactions, meaning there’s
less opportunity to get it on.
So our intercourse is getting in the way of
our intercourse.
One of Twenge’s co-authors, Ryne Sherman,
suggested that the abundance of other outlets
like pornography or the rise in sexual education
and awareness of sexually transmitted diseases
may lead to more prudent youth.
It’s also possible that we have a more casual
definition of casual sex, so it only looks
like we’re not getting busy.
Anthropologist Dr. Helen Fisher told Business
Insider that the casual hookups may be leading
to meaningful relationships when millennials
catch feelings for their partner.
Fisher also thinks that online dating apps
are actually having a negative impact on our
hookups.
When people are presented with so many choices,
they’re less likely to pick one, a phenomenon
I’m calling “App-stinence.”
All these factors may have lead to our sex
drives hitting the brakes, but none have been
looked at in depth.
So if you’re a millennial and your parents
think your generation is too frisky, be comforted
knowing that your parents probably had way
more sex than you.
Wait that’s not comforting at all!
If you’re trying to buck statistics, you
know what will set you apart from the shirtless
bros on tinder?
Your own website.
And no domain extension will help you tell
your story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain
name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
Of course we may be less frisky because we’re
carrying around a few more pounds than our
parents too.
To find out why, Julia explores that here.
Why do you think millennials aren’t doing
the dirty horizontal mambo?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to like this video, and subscribe for a new
episode of DNews every day of the week.